uh the question of course now is how
officials here
going to brace for this later search i
want to bring in texas department of
public safety lieutenant chris oliveiras
uh who joins us now
so what's what's the plan i mean
obviously this is so well organized and
so brazen is so confident
how
what happens when they get to our border
well great to be with you charles so we
are closely monitoring this caravan
right now we can we can just we can
mobilize resources at a moment's notice
uh we have a great partner with the
texas national guard who has deployed
thousands of resources to the southern
border as well and more to come but i
can tell you right now charles what took
place in del rio a few weeks ago with
the haitians texas will not allow that
that's not going to happen again we are
closely monitoring this caravan and we
will take a proactive approach we work
closely with our federal partners the
the question is
once they get to a certain location
where are they going to break off and
where they're going to end up that's
what we need to focus on but i can tell
you right now we have plenty of assets
in place that we can we can uh deter
this caravan from surging the southern
border that's what we have that's what
that's what we're focused on right now
what do you think the message was then
that uh that again you've got folks from
all over the planet really it's uh it's
a it's like a united nations and
uh there's a qr code uh it's a lot of
money had to go into the organization of
all of this
what do you think the message was just
get to the border even even you know and
you mentioned your federal partners uh
once you get past the the border patrol
some federal agency will make it easier
for you to to get into the united states
right that's the issue right now the
issue is that the federal government has
sent out this message that right now is
a time to come to the u.s because you
will be led into the country and that's
why you see these large groups of
caravans that are searching the border
we saw that in del rio a few weeks ago
we're continuing to see that day in and
day out along the southern border we
still have thousands that are coming
across the border every single day so
the problem is the messaging the
messaging is right now come to the u.s
because you will be let free
into the country because there is no
consequences there is no rule of law
that's being uh enforced by the federal
government that's why texas is stepping
in we are stepping in and we are going
to do what we can as far as with the
resources that we have to contain this
surge and also not only that charles but
we also are arresting illegal immigrants
that are coming across that are
violating state law for criminal
trespass so we are making arrests we
have made over 1400 arrests since july
so the message that we are sending is
that don't come to texas if you do you
will be arrested you will be apprehended
you will be played be placed behind bars
yeah 1.7 million apprehensions in the
fiscal year
shattering all records on that that have
been out there and still these
caravans organizat
are you upset are you frustrated with
the mexican government uh you know that
wasn't a lot of resistance that was put
up there
right so that that's that's something
that the federal government our federal
government needs to work out with the
mexican government they got to put more
pressure on them to stop these caravans
to make it further north and right now
what we saw in some of those videos
that's not taking place um they really
got to take a stance and enforce and
have some action to prevent these curve
events but right now there's so much
money being involved with human
smuggling just to just to give you an
insight
right now human smugglers are making
well over 100 million dollars a week
just on human smuggling that's not even
narcotics so there's so much money
involved with these cartels and these
smuggling organizations they have so
much power right now that it's going to
be very difficult and challenging to
shut these groups down because as long
as the message is being sent to come to
the u.s we're going to continue seeing
these caravans uh making their way to
the southern border chris i got to wrap
this up and send me that 100 million a
week
that's correct that's that's what we're
getting from our resources from our
source is that these human smugglers are
making well over 100 million dollars a
week just on human smuggling not even
narcotics just human smuggling wow chris
be safe thank you very much we always
appreciate it